tens of thousands of people are being
evacuated from the area around a volcano
on the caribbean island of
vincent after it began erupting on
friday the volcano has been spewing
smoke and ash across the island
it had been dormant for decades until
december 2020 when it began showing
signs of activity
watch it the eruption ejected smoke
kilometers high into the air
clear my god
created an ash cloud so thick it hid the
sun
poor visibility forced airlines to
cancel flights to and from saint vincent
hey this this load uh explosion i hate
that smoke smoke
start to go up in there so yeah i mean i
just get panic understanding just tell
me brother
there we go over 16 000 people living
near the volcano were ordered to leave
the area for their own
safety by saint vincent's prime minister
ralph gonsalves
residents queued for minibuses taking
only what they could carry with them
but there weren't enough places for
everyone
in some regions evacuation efforts
didn't go according to plan
areas that were supposed to be moved by
buses
that did not materialize i don't know
where the breakdown happened but
it did not materialize as a result quite
a number of persons were late on the
road
looking for bus transportation local
people
boarded ferries at night to neighboring
islands
dominica granada and antigua have agreed
to accept evacuees from saint vincent
but only those people who are already
vaccinated against the coronavirus
and shelters on the island have to limit
the number of people they can admit
to prevent coronavirus outbreaks
scientists from the university of the
west indies
warned that the volcano could keep
erupting for days or weeks